[Music]
in keeping up with the kids news
submitted by take notes a high school
teacher keeps a spreadsheet of slang
words so he can figure out what his
students are saying Wow
so [ __ ] keyboard this to me I feel
like I need it dude everyone say a toxic
now and I'm like what is this what is
this it's a new one [ __ ] people are like
oh this person is toxic
these people are toxic you know what
that means yeah oh I get it but I'm like
what's exactly the content it's not a
biohazard is it you're right
well they are to your soul that's been
around I only hear things after they've
been around for a couple years
what about like oh they're shook like
generally I mean like oh you got me [ __ ]
oh yeah per though do you know what that
means
vaguely oh I think you feel like on the
verge of Parkinson's he's right is it
was like they surprised me I think it's
like I'm very surprised or like oh that
makes me pressed listen I love press
yeah that's when you're like upset
something has you high yeah wait what is
it called press pressed how do you use
it in a sentence like leg let's just
hold you press that's gonna make me part
like I'm gonna get pressed yeah can you
say it what else everyone second law
comes up yeah if you're around my house
and you don't hit me up and hang out and
I'll be pressed I don't want to be press
huh have you guys heard it is it for
depressed
no it's for like pimp you like an iron
like pressed like you're hot you're
upset oh we're all wearing old man
makeup right now look is it like car
like you're really cold you poor guys
like a month he runs out of the
sociology teacher named James Callaghan
well she better knows she's sociologists
James bro oh you heard Jane yeah named
James Callaghan
he's a 43 year old teacher from
Massachusetts
he's a Masshole he looks like you would
ask what is pressed what's this he break
that egg that went viral yeah is it
Dacula Genting I look like I'm three
years younger than him he's very cute
looking got three years I'll be he he I
was I was a jock more when he was a
senior Oh
so this tweets went viral it's a
screenshot of this document and it says
my sociology professor keeps an
alphabetic alphabetic list of new slang
terms he learns from students and I will
never get over it
can you read some this is real one run
that the whole thing because of this
going viral
people started inputting the actual
address I were in the screenshots and so
they created this separate Google sheet
because it was crashing the school
servers oh wow yeah so there's a hint
that is so cute of force why doesn't he
just go to uh urbandictionary.com forest
America unnecessarily excessive effort
he doesn't know bread this is high
school turn so some of these we wouldn't
even read equals money they've been
saying that since the seventies yeah
Turkey [ __ ] yeah exactly I love that
that's like night radio [ __ ] cracky
someone who smokes
Jules Jules what's Jules the little
Timmy
it looks like a USB stick mm-hmm but you
smoke oh okay Oh Julia band did it I
didn't I'm sleeping yeah like everything
this is so [ __ ] cute it's all
color-coded [ __ ] yeah box a modern
enjoyable song Balta I am about to Oh
boda Wow this batter because instead of
like Hin like making the kids speak
proper English he's like okay let me
connect with them and understand what
they're saying so that like I am NOT
like out of the loop so tell us to be
hip to the lingo that's so dope I love
hai ki I love hai ki I like hai ki hai
ki and low-key yeah very obvious madman
big med I never heard of John gotta
blast of Jimmy Neutron you know I think
I'm a blast and that's amazing the game
what's the game old life that's so good
oh my god dead dogs on dogs see dead s
I'm serious are you serious are you
dogs on dogs dead dogs dead dogs back in
our day it was like it's like put it on
something like put on your mom I don't
know whatever but now I guess it's dead
dogs on dos swear you swear yeah yeah
yeah yeah thing / hyping offering
compliments that or feeding ones ego I'm
trying to be like you
this is so fun dude in like 40 years
there's gonna be like old people and
they're gonna like tell you I'm dead-ass
on this one depressing everyone has
their lingo put on your mommy era
because then it's the water like the
seventies terms are the eighties terms
the jive turkeys like jive Turkey right
on the mom
I still say bomb I mean bomb is okay but
dub can we finally give props to cool
cool made it like 40 years dude cool is
that now that's crazy
run universally I mean that's just one
of those words whoever invented that pat
yourself on the back right cool is the
youtuber who never got a relevant way
danke Schoen tov Great Depression era -
cool cuz they did jazz musicians use
cool oh maybe cool cat yeah like yeah
cool daddy-o I feel like even Elvis said
cool dude I feel like everybody's so
cool Jesus ed cool
well jazz people said that we know I
will sell it that's true no I want to
know how so wait how was this discovered
real quick slaps high-quality you will
be okay nunya none of your business
yep I know that one on blast he put it
in like that box yeah yeah I have to
squint so I can read it hope that's
young listen to them or if he like had
help hmm like if somebody was helping
him I know cuz I'm surprised students
didn't roll he didn't write Shady
true I would have told him solidia a
good time yeah I never heard that one
liddie I don't ever want to hear it yeah
like oh yeah what is it like lit and
what what Shoei oh yes remember when um
slang used to be regional - like NorCal
people spoke different from like hella
yeah but no people sent son a lot but
see we used to say hello in high school
yeah it started changing with all that
amusing stuff like that okay whatever it
was a Bay Area thing I'm like what I've
always said hello it came over pretty
quick I'd say but it's got MTV well it
got on the ships when they were coming
over it snuck into the boxes yeah on the
princess Croatians yeah yeah well how
was this discovered again so the last
one a student
tweeted out in that tweet went viral oh
so she just happened to see it when he
had it up um I don't know I don't know
joke so like that one I don't know what
this student I don't know how he came
across it oh I see I feel like even Will
Smith needs this when he talks to Jaden
oh yeah because he innovated a different
like generation of cool but like flight
Jaden as I got another one he also needs
a space communicator to talk a little
bit crazy yeah well this is the last one
wig snatched wigs net a term for an
impressive or unimpressive act slash
appearance that's from the gaze by the
way which one is and wig snap wig
snatched snatched witless way better
what does it mean again it just means
your balls because somebody like did
something so well like a performance or
yeah I got I got wigged off somebody
wake me off how old are you I can't be
this much 28 dude what nothing I'm like
five years older than you know I might
as well be fifty years old it no it
there is a difference
and it's getting like smaller yeah as to
like how things change and like let's
culture it depends if you care about pop
culture or not - cuz there's definitely
people older they knew that are into the
[ __ ] depends on your friends - like when
we go to playlist live or VidCon if I go
on a YouTube circle and everyone's
talking like that I'm already like
[Music]
[Laughter]
aren't saying this [ __ ] yeah where
companies might be that's where I blend
in is with investment bankers listen
that's that's how we used to do it mine
a born in the eighties it's like a queen
way but you just do one finger no you do
it no you have
my Sam teaching you some fancy Hey well
it's like we're in a movie that's right
another recipe I forgot what a damn but
I haven't heard that song in so long
yeah quick little wrists or something
like that I don't want to even guess I'm
gonna sound so stupid
I don't know my next i G caption is
gonna be a mixture of all those words
hopefully they wiggle wrists no it's
like that means have you seen like the
videos of like that um it'll have a
caption like my mom trying to fit in
with my friends and it's just like oh
give me the T hunty like my wig ha I'm
dead like it's just like like I've
already reached that age really can't
use new terms like I feel too old for
that I'm only 29 but like I don't think
I can use any internet turnover and
weird you hear isaac using those house
no no the only one which i think i think
is really cute so i have an 11 year old
son and so i'll hear him talking to his
friends and he'll just say bro like 10
times in one sentence bro bro did you
see that bro nah bro and i'm like so
cute could be so little he's like
already like using that type of
vernacular I don't know it's really cute
I like it but I haven't heard him say
any of these so bro made a comeback huh
or actually dance or like you would dab
a lot oh cool
does this teacher know that his list has
been exposed yes
so because of that [ __ ] my secrets out
yeah so he said look at that here you go
Internet and then the link to the drive
and says if you're feeling philanthropic
here are two programs in our community
that need funding and then he put two
weeks what a cool guy use that he used
Fame in a good way
what a good teacher dude I love this guy
he's like it's amazing to me how words
generate new meanings depending on the
generation to a gen Xer like myself a
snack is a small portion of food one
would have between meals
usage in actually maybe a handful of
cheese's or some peanuts however to Gen
Z a snack is an attractive person or
someone who looks good it is used as a
compliment I find that fascinating but
hilarious as
I love it what are we gentlemen we're in
between yeah well us we're clean
yeah cuz we can be Millennials but were
like at the tail end I thought
millennial and why was the fam I don't
know I don't know anything why the a
yeah maybe why yeah I think you're right
cuz I remember someone going like why
bother with you guys and I'm like oh I
love like you said how words come back
and [ __ ] cuz like if you're in the like
if you're like my grandpa's I'm [ __ ]
you're like you're like back in my day
debt is something that we said about our
friends in Vietnam oh now you guys are
saying that it's just a funny joke I
guess so yeah really well thank you hey
yeah Peyton paid a lot of attention to
that man because I had to
[Music]